thank you before I get started I just
want to thank all the organizers of this
conference this has been fantastic I've
had a really good time these last few
days alright so I am Louie Montez Montez
Liu on most social network things
Twitter and github and wherever else
that handle is still available like Alex
just mentioned I run ice dev in the u.s.
we do full stack JavaScript so no js'
reactor or whatever up front and we've
actually got a little further than that
recent years going past the browser and
into hardware IOT related projects so
we're an Internet of Things company
mostly lately so just this past Consumer
Electronics Show in Las Vegas there was
a bunch of really really cool products
released with Internet connectivity in
fact one of them you could at least one
of them you can use your your iPhone
well only your iPhone no Android support
and you know search for their product
install their app accept permissions
sign up discover on the network locally
device press a button on your screen and
a button would be pressed in the
physical world right in front of you so
what a time to be alive right all right
so of course IOT has been mostly
marketing but there is actually some
tech that's come out of this right so
recent years there's been a few things
that have helped us to actually realize
some of these amazing products there's
been a whole lot of really inexpensive
boards right Arduino like over the last
decade raspberry pi many things are you
know really easy to get started with so
we could prototype things really quickly
it also helps that you know half the
people in the world have a super
computer in their pocket with you know
an internet connection that helps out
quite a bit for IOT as well but the you
know one of the things I'm really
interested though is just sort of the
ubiquitous bi-directional communication
right we've you know historically
especially with the web have made
requests got responses
we have been doing a lot more server
push in recent years and it's gotten a
lot easier to do it that's a that's a
big part of this let's start off with
the embedded hardware so we our front
end or at least since this is the front
in half of the conference there's
probably a lot of JavaScript developers
in here and anybody that wanted to do
JavaScript and robotics or little IOT
things has probably started here so the
first commit to the node serial port
repository was September 7 2010 by Chris
Williams and this sort of started the
whole node bots movement so let's say
well before I get there with with node
serial port I mean it's a very popular
project now it's got a lot of
contributors but what I really like what
they did is a really simple API so this
should look familiar to anybody who's
done node it's an event emitter right so
we can if we want to read data or at
least the data events as they come you
know to a sort of a synchronously we
just add an event listener so on data
and we get we get some data every time
that comes across the wire and if we
want to write data we're typically
sending like a buffer a node buffer or
you went eight array and you know we
just have a series of bytes and you know
we use Express those is like hex codes
so or 0 to 255 or you know if you want
to be real specific there with bits you
can do that as a as a literal in
JavaScript so let's say I want to
connect using JavaScript using node.js
specifically to a piece of hardware like
an Arduino Uno so note so your port is
perfect for this and the way this has
been working histórico leas we have our
node program fire up establish a
connection to the serial port and first
thing we do is we you know ask the
arduino what its version is and that
version is the version of firmata so
this is a common sketch that we've been
using to to automate these pins so every
one of these arduino is or one of these
boards have general-purpose inputs
outputs so we can turn switches on we
can listen for changes in current so
that we
can you like connect a sensor things
like that but Fermont is a really good
way of doing this especially and it
doesn't really have to be node but this
is really easy to do with node and you
know of course there this thing shoots
us back a message asynchronously of you
know what it's version is and then
typically the process is okay
Arduino what can you do so give me a
capability I'm gonna do a capability
query and you're going to string me back
all the pin descriptions like you know
pin thirteen can do digital in and out
and you know pin three can do pulse
width modulation like variable amounts
of current going out things like that
all right sweet we've got a description
of the pins we've sort of bootstrap this
connection and we could do something
like yay turn on pin 13 so the reason we
always do this is the hello world of
electronics right we need to see that
something actually happened from our
JavaScript code or whatever language to
the physical world and that's why I
turning on an LED always seems silly
that we're making all these steps to
flip a light switch but it's to show
that we have connectivity and that
everything's working of course we don't
want to send all those bytes and know
how to do like what the things are in
those last slides those were the actual
bytes that are going across for a
Fermata but that's a lot to do so fast
forward a couple years after node serial
port and Rick Waldron made the first
commits to the johnny-five library which
is basically an abstraction for doing
robotics and this has become a very
popular project and over a hundred
contributors it's it's really good stuff
and instead of having to know what to
send down the serial port exactly we've
got some abstraction like create a board
when that boards ready maybe create an
LED and then Blake it or you know have a
sensor that gives us the temperature or
have a you know servo motor to move a
robot's arm and you know we have like
high-level api's for all this and fast
forward a couple more years and Rick did
the first decoupling of making it
something specific to Arduino and
allowed for other boards so he made the
the Galileo which was an Intel board he
got that to work and then everybody else
sort of jumped on board people all over
the world
creating plugins these i/o classes that
can go into johnny-five
to support all kinds of other hardware
and some of these boards were you know a
lot more powerful than saying Arduino so
we could run you know Linux and nodejs
directly on the board so they wouldn't
have to be tethered at all the robot
logic is all happening right there on
the on the embedded platform and over
these last few years the the movement of
node bots johnny-five
all of this you know there's been robots
conf there's been a lot of stuff at Jas
confident and the movement has grown
quite a bit with people doing JavaScript
and robotics and once a year there's
international node BOTS day so all over
the world people get together and build
robots and this is the event that
happens over in Phoenix and there's been
four of them so far so four years in row
started off just doing the tethered
Arduino thing to firmata moved on to
Wi-Fi and eventually Bluetooth so it's
it's been progressing and you know it's
a whole day of robotics and at the end
of the day we smash the robots into each
other it's kind of fun and you know
there's been a whole lot of creativity
that's come out of that as well
so you know people start by putting the
robot together and getting the thing to
move but then they want to do something
like oh I want to put a web dashboard on
front of this thing so I can have some
buttons and things too you know to build
a UI more than just you know command
line node and so typically we will have
a node server right like Express or
happy or something like that and that
takes requests in fires up johnny-five
you know and you build a dashboard and
then you're like okay but I want this
really you know interactive I don't want
to just make Ajax calls for my front-end
I want to do like have sensors push you
know eventsource down or use socket IO
you know some web sockets to do things
in real time from my from my dashboard
to my node process running johnny-five
or MQTT which is another iot type
transport to do publish and subscribe
back you know over a WebSocket or just a
direct TCP socket now back to that and
but so that's it that's a great start
and what I really like about progressive
web apps is you know there's there's
been a couple of great talks already on
this so I'm not gonna go to detail onto
what the progressive web apps are but
weird you know at high level there's a
serviceworker that
such things so that we all network
requests can go through that so we can
run the things offline and get better
manifest into things that we can get add
to homescreen button we can do push
notifications so we can have like a
server send a message to our service
worker wake it up maybe bring up the
page but it could also send up an
encrypted payload as well that used to
be a thing we just send a notification
and then the web page or the service
worker would tell the web page to make
requests to get data to come back but we
can just do that one thing now and you
know they're supposed to also be fast
secure and responsive but and this is
really good and we can just add that
right now to these existing things we've
been doing you know with johnny-five and
the IOT um but that just kind of gets us
to where native apps are in a way right
like that is not pushing it forward as
much as like catching up to two native
Android iOS applications but there are
some things that the web just does
better and at least in my experience
here not you know not just the
deployment and and you know not being in
a walled garden or anything like that
but what's already been talked about as
well is WebRTC now this is actually a
really big deal in this wides i've heard
a couple of talks here about this
already and the key is it was really
good in really detail and this is not
detailed but just real simple story here
imagine we got we'll call him Peter and
Peter wants to send something really
important over to his good buddy varus
now Peter doesn't really trust like
facebook Messenger or our Google Chat so
he doesn't want to go through somebody
else's network to send this important
information over he wants to just send
it directly to him it was discussed
before there there are some things that
have to happen we can't just go straight
you know peer to peer we have to go
through at the very very minimum we have
a stun server which is how you know our
brows are on one side of the internet
figures out how to tunnel out and so he
gets response back from the stun server
and what does that look like how does he
take that stun message use his browser
to create something that he needs to get
over to varus so he creates this offer
it's about 5k worth of JSON
and I don't understand everything in
this but what's important is he needs to
get that over so we talked there was
talked earlier about a signaling server
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
server in fact while a WebSocket like
between two two peers could be a really
quick way to get this 5k over to the
other person it's not nearly as fast as
a raven so a raven can have that message
bundled up and go over to the other guy
Varys on this in this case you know can
can transcribe that message you could
put that right into his browser who
talks to a Sun server and gets an answer
that answer looked very similar another
big blob of JSON that has to get back to
Peter now this stuff could be all like I
said out of bound that was what was
mentioned earlier but it doesn't have to
be an actual signaling server it could
be anything and he doesn't like Ravens
he's going to send this back over Gmail
so he could just copy and paste it and
yay Peter is able to establish now a
direct link and just like we had a sort
of the bi-directional communication with
serial port like we have with WebSockets
on message very important you don't one
of them could read events that come in
and of course either one of them could
can send things out so so very helpful
and very helpful for for IOT
applications and sort of expanding what
we're able to do with the web using
using peer connections but okay what's
that got to do with putting browser
robotics together just think of all
these things as a toolbox right to
connect every little every little piece
but can we just take johnny-five and use
webpack or browserify and just expect it
to work and talk to talk to a piece of
hardware in Arduino typically what do we
do we are we have some problem like this
with the web so we'd want to wrap it in
some sort of thing and deploy it to a
store to have more access or something
right well you might not need to do that
you might not need a wrapper you might
be able to do these things directly from
a browser
okay so anybody who heard of MIDI
old-school write Middies great and midis
for making music right MIDI is for
playing notes or receiving notes it is
for that but what you can do is emulate
a MIDI device so there's a whole bunch
of different Arduino zhh that can
emulate any USB peripheral it's just a
very small amount of code some of the
newer maker Arduino is the older of
Leonardo micro they cannot be any
peripheral USB perfectly one and there's
a very easy to use Arduino library to to
make USB devices but also another layer
on top of that to say be a MIDI device
okay so but the MIDI protocol is
actually pretty pretty constrained right
we know there are certain things we can
do like play a note on this channel you
know with the first byte which key you
know 0 to 127 what velocity we're going
to strike that key so for like playing a
piano is on this channel this note this
velocity but it turns out even though
were were were constrained to what those
bytes are allowed to be that range the
the peripheral that we want to talk to
doesn't really care but if you think
about it if we've got like 64 values in
the first byte that we can be that's six
bits of arbitrary data 0 to 127 in the
middle of 0 to 127 another 7 bit 70s we
got 20 bits to play in because it
doesn't actually have to be a musical
instrument and what's really nice about
this is since this seems like such a
benign thing to do to just send notes or
listen for notes you can usually get
away with the browser not even prompting
you for access to MIDI ports which is
very handy and just like the other API
is that I was saying where we have a
read and write this is just as simple
it's not you know the typical event
emitter but it is you know we're putting
a callback of what happens when a MIDI
message comes in we got data and our
output send takes yet another array
buffer another unit array or a buffer of
bytes
however these need to be in that
format right they need to be in those
ranges or they'll throw an exception in
the browser you know the thing about
like doing that low-level bit
manipulation is that I heard years and
years didn't ever have to do that it
didn't help me to make an enterprise
application to know how to move bits
around but some people have been doing
this and they've made some really cool
libraries on top of it so if you just
take the time to figure out okay yeah
this like bit shifting and I don't want
to do all that but if you just spend a
little bit of time on that you might be
able to enable some piece of hardware
that is very constrained and that you
really need to worry about just what's
going into it so the stuff that you
might have done in computer science that
didn't have a whole lot of use very
useful if you're doing any of this
robotic stuff okay so if you don't want
to use MIDI although MIDI is super great
for this right now because MIDI is
available it's been for a few years at
least in Chrome it's there's an open
issue on Firefox and there has been some
work actually just three weeks ago there
was a commit to you input stuff it's not
it's not production ready yet though web
USB however as of Wednesday is stable in
chrome 61 so we can use this or what
what is web USB that sounds like super
dangerous right like just generic web
USB access well there's a lot to getting
to the web us to a USB port through Web
USB you have to be on htps the you can't
even start until it you know you answer
a dialogue that's popped up and that
dialogue is prompted by the Dom click so
you can't just load a page and have it
have it connect you have to instantiate
that from a user interaction you also
have to put filtering criteria of just
which devices you're looking for you
have to be real specific and say it's
this particular vendor and product ID so
but once you get past all of that
you know is if you're building for a
specific device this isn't too bad
in fact all of those devices that I was
just showing that can do MIDI can also
do this Web USB and then you're not
constrained to just certain white so you
just get to full blast bytes back and
forth to a device from the browser
and this is a little bit more
complicated cuz there's more options on
how you send things what these bulk
transfers and more transactional things
but in the end really just reading data
sending data input/output just like
everything else and we're dealing with
with arrays of bytes just the same
okay so Bluetooth another way of
connecting now Bluetooth historically if
you've never done like bluetooth for
robotics Bluetooth has been about like
pairing your phone to your speakers or
something like that right these are
older Bluetooth profiles but as a
Bluetooth 4 which has been around for
for several years now we've got the
ability to do Bluetooth Low Energy
devices and this is actually very very
different than the old way of pairing
Bluetooth low-energy devices let's
something like go to sleep for a long
time wake up do a thing one of the
things that they go to sleep for and
wake up is to beacon so imagine this
little tiny device running on this coin
cell battery sleeps most of the time
wakes up once a minute or however
whatever interval you configured it for
and I don't know shoots out a URL like
some people in the audience tend to do
and that is called the physical web it's
using a byte format called Eddystone
it's basically encoding a URL into this
packet that's being advertised every so
often and this is actually really cool
in that it gives us a starting point
right so if you've got this URL that's
coming up and it just shows up on your
phone out of nowhere and that might be
because there's a piece of hardware that
we might want to interact with and we
can take that a step further cool we're
at this URL we've opened up this say
progressive web app to to talk to
something potentially directly so the
Bluetooth Low Energy stuff unlike the
the the older style Bluetooth the you
know Bluetooth 4 on up has what we're
calling bluetooth services so imagine
something like a heart rate monitor is
got a heart rate service I got multiple
services as well now these services have
characteristics a characteristic is like
where the data is accessed at so if a
service is a heart rate monitor so we
might
you know asked for subscribe to
notifications on heart rate changes so
we're able to read like events in in
real time or we could potentially have a
character is that something back and
this heart rate monitor is just an
example because it's one that's sort of
already unknown we're using like service
IDs that are common but we could make
these up these could be anything so this
is like an arbitrary communications
channel that doesn't have to be
something that you know like some
approved vendor specified you can grab a
Bluetooth Arduino and just say I'm gonna
create a service that does this thing
and if anybody's done a Bluetooth Low
Energy with node they've likely been
using Sandeep mysteries project called
Noble and Nobles great for node very
easy to use API what I like about noble
as well is since a lot of node projects
like the rolling spider the the little
drone that's web Bluetooth all of these
things that were written against the
noble API there's now a shim so what you
can take your noble nodejs bluetooth
code and get that to run on top of web
bluetooth using using like browserify or
web pack and okay so so that's pretty
cool we can establish a connection this
also had when we're using web Bluetooth
when we want to establish a connection
we have some similar constraints to what
we were doing with web USB so with web
USB it has to be an SSL sire HTTP on
there has to be some user interaction we
have to specify just which services we
want to talk to you as well a dialog
will come up and we'll connect to and
then we'll actually pair with the device
and once we're paired it's a one-to-one
thing a device connected to a to a
computer to a to a phone and once we
have one of these service connections
and we sort of iterate through its
characteristics we can ask for on data
or write just like the event emitter
just like serial port and in fact a lot
of these Bluetooth devices are using a
common service called Nordic you aren't
and that basically ends up being just
like serial port except it's it's
Wireless and there is a Bluetooth
low-energy serial port implementation
that we could plug into Fermata and do
the the robotics that way if we want to
okay
so here's another one and this one's
super super early so this is very
subject to change I imagine but there is
a w3c spec on top of it and that's near
field communication so it's like I said
it's really early but yet another way
for us to take a device and potentially
send arbitrary bytes between a couple of
devices right so we can have our phone
which has an NFC reader and it could
also project NFC messages what does that
look like if we want to expose some
bytes to something else that's going to
pick those up we're using web NFC push
so navigator NFC push hello world if
something wants to read that so on the
other side it can set a watch to listen
for NFC messages that it gets close to
right so NFC watch do something all
promise based and that should work
pretty well okay so I went faster than I
should have but I'm gonna start doing
demos that hardware demos are the
dumbest thing that you could possibly do
as a speaker so I'm gonna do the dumbest
thing possible as a speaker and do a
hardware demo a little bit of setup here
those leonardo's the those things that
can do USB peripheral this is a knockoff
a pro micro that was like a three dollar
version of that but it's able to use a
library so that's pretty cool the top
right thing that is a accelerometer from
a tehsil tehsil is one of those other
boards that's supported by Johnny Five
what I really like about what they did
is those modules yeah they're they like
they fit really well into a Tesla so
they're really great for a Tesla but
they're also using a common standard to
communicate something called I squared C
it's in true yeah I to see look it up
anyways it's a way to connect just
microcontrollers to microcontrollers
integrated circuits to integrate
circuits and we can take the
accelerometer data off of that and push
it into this Arduino now why do I have a
QR code because there's you know they're
new sort of experimental web api that
kind of want to show off as well Jen in
her talk yesterday showed what what they
were doing with faces and faces are
really cool because you get you know the
position of the face and potentially
where the eyes and mouth are at and like
a bounding box around somebody's head
what I like about the QR code part of
the shape recognition API is you could
have data in there right so that that's
cool because we could have position but
we could also have data and if we if
we're doing IOT things we typically have
our data described as our device is
described as a UUID right if anybody's
done anything with IOT it's basically 16
bytes is this big ugly number if you're
gonna do that
don't put the dashes in it for some
reason we do like 32 characters and four
dashes and I don't know who came up with
that or what the reasoning is but 36
characters is just past the threshold of
cool QR codes and into the really like
nasty high resolution ones so just take
out those four dashes and then you got
an easier to read QR code saver tip for
the day and the face here this little
robot so QR codes are kind of ugly uu
IDs are kind of ugly but hashing things
into cute rock robots are really cool
right so if we decide like these bytes
mean this color and all that so there is
an algorithm in this demo that if you
put any QR code you get a somewhat
unique ish robot face out of it okay a
little bit more setup here since this is
front-end video tag everybody knows what
a video tag is in html5 video inline
styles I'm sure somebody Ella about me
putting an inline style there but I want
to put the video in the back canvas in
the front right a little bit more demo
set up three J s was discussed
three Jas is awesome three Jas has this
trick you can do where you can say the
Alpha on your renderer is you can make
it transparent and you could set a clear
color I'm not sure why it all works like
this but what this does is gives us a
three J s without a background right so
a transparent three J s and it's a
little bit more setup the barcode
detector API which I've gotten here can
also run in a web worker so even if it's
a CPU intensive tasks we can background
that in a thread can't with chrome 61
also canvas off-screen canvas was added
but we don't need that for this all we
need to do is get our image data into
into the web worker and that that image
data if we post to the web worker is
processed there's also in this
particular demo a fallback so I do want
to use the fallback though because the
only good QR code scanner that I found
that's completely JavaScript based
doesn't give quite the same effect it
gives us three points the one that's
built in gives us four points around a
thing and that makes a difference for
what I'm gonna do here although this the
other way still works but but the native
barcode detection experimental works
better
okay so that was way too much setup for
for this demo but okay so like I said
video we could just use getusermedia to
put into that video and we can use the
QR code scanning now what this is doing
is this is not a real AR framework right
like a rjs go use that there's another
one that just came out by by Google the
the stuff that I've seen Jerome I didn't
do with Arg s is really cool but what
this is doing is if we're gonna use a
marker like a rjs is doing maybe that
marker should be a little bit more
significant and just hey there is a
thing here well that thing could
correspond to something that's actually
a device that we can read and write data
to write so if you have something to say
is simple also this isn't a plastic box
because I've done demos before without
plus
boxes if you're ever gonna do hardware
demo put it in a plastic box or you'll
totally screw it all up if we take
accelerometer data and then we encode it
as MIDI bytes then we can take sensor
data as match that up with something in
the real world so just think this is
sort of the start of okay we can have
IOT devices you know either beaconing or
you know tethered or whatever that are
emitting data that correspond to
something in the real world that we're
able to then change the display with
augmented reality alright and all of
this right here as we've done without
like any major toolkit other than three
Jas but if you don't have to use that if
you know how to do the like really crazy
WebGL stuff without three Jas so it
doesn't really need much more than we're
scanning a QR code and finding that
position there was a little bit of math
here that I had to learn to do that
right like we're taking four points but
I'm able to get like angles and stuff
out of it because we can translate those
four points into 3d coordinate space
with something called a posit a
logarithm I don't even know what to
search for but I managed to eventually
find that so anyways that's about the
gist of it so just think about
potentially some of these these tools
that we have this this sort of toy box
of things that we have now in browser
that we can we can just build things on
top of and stitch together IOT AR you
know web BR all of that it's just been a
lot of fun lately kind of connecting to
the pieces that it's all I got
[Applause]